because there's things like Alpha we're  doing where you have this dude that just  rocked your world just changed your life  and you can never get him out of your  brain because of all the partners you've  been with and then you have just areas  where if you slept with all these dudes  your ability to is a parabon parabon  with your husband is going to be hard  because you've just freely given  yourself to all these other dudes to  where when it comes to your husband is  going to be like yeah I love him but he  doesn't do this this like this person  did that person that person did so it's  like you have all these bits and pieces  of these other dudes that just do